zu liefern und und länder haben beraten
und beschlossen und darüber informieren
sie jetzt die bundeskanzlerin der
regierende bürgermeister und der
bayerische ministerpräsident vor
bundeskanzlerin ja meine damen und
herren wir haben heute in einer
video-konferenz mit der präsenz der
beiden ministerpräsidenten beraten und
diese beratungen in einer sehr ernsten
lage statt
uns ist allen bewusst dass viele
menschen wahrscheinlich millionen von
menschen heute mit großer erwartung aber
auch mit sorge auf diese beratungen
geschaut haben und bei allem was wir
heute beraten und beschlossen haben
hatten wir natürlich auch immer diese
menschen im blick auf der einen seite
ihre gesundheit aber auch ihre arbeit
und ihre wirtschaftliche situation
ich will bevor ich die beschlüsse im
einzelnen noch erläutere ein wenig
genauer sagen was die derzeitige
pandemie lage so ernst macht
es geht hier darum dass das tempo des
virus oder seiner verbreitung besonders
hoch ist wir erleben einen
exponentiellen anstieg der zahlen mit
verdopplung zeiten die sich weiter
verkürzt haben
heute war es zum beispiel doppelt so
viele infektionen neuinfektionen wie vor
einer woche
und so ist es auch bei anderen wichtigen
indikatoren zum beispiel bei dem so
wichtigen indikator der auf der
intensivstation behandelten menschen
auch hier haben sich die zahlen in den
letzten zehn tagen verdoppelt und
verdoppelt hat sich auch die zahl der
koma patientin die künstlich beatmet
werden müssen und zwar in den letzten
neun tagen das zeigt eigentlich also die
dynamik desinfektions geschehens und wir
können sagen dass unser
gesundheitssystem heute noch mit dieser
herausforderung fertig wird aber wenn es
bei diesem tempo der infektion bleibt
dann kommen wir binnen wochen an die
grenzen der leistungsfähigkeit des
gesundheitssystems
der verband der intensivmediziner zu
beispiel hat sich hatte uns noch einmal
auf die sich zuspitzende situation
hingewiesen
und deshalb ist vollkommen klar wir
müssen handeln und zwar jetzt und zwar
müssen wir handeln um eine akute
nationalen gesundheitsrat notlage zu
vermeiden wir wollen nicht in eine
solche nationale gesundheitsnotfall
hineinkommen und dafür müssen wir
maßnahmen ergreifen
das wichtigste instrument ich habe
darüber sehr oft gesprochen
zur eindämmung einer pandemie ist die
nachverfolgung der kontakte jedes
infizierten und genau dieses wichtigste
instrument stellt uns an vielen stellen
nicht mehr zur verfügung weil die
gesundheitsämter an die grenze dessen
gekommen sind was sie nachverfolgen
können
und das bedeutet nichts anderes als dass
infektionsketten nicht mehr unterbrochen
werden können und dass dann die
kontrolle über die ausbreitung des virus
verloren geht und das muss verändert
werden
wir merken dass zum teil auch schon in
verschiedenen bereichen der
infrastruktur dass immer mehr menschen
auch infiziert sind und wir wissen das
geht dann nicht nur an die
leistungsfähigkeit grenze des
gesundheitssystems sondern auch der
gesamten infrastruktur unseres landes
das heißt die kurve muss wieder
abflachen und die zahl der
neuinfektionen muss sich erst
stabilisieren und dann weiter sinken
damit wir die nachverfolgbarkeit und sie
wissen dass wir die bei etwa 50 pro
100000 in sieben tagen neu infizierten
angesetzt haben damit für die
nachvollziehbarkeit der kontakte wieder
herstellen können
wir haben im frühjahr erlebt dass es uns
gelungen ist diese abflachung und diese
senkung der kurve zu schaffen und zwar
vor allem durch die vernunft und
solidarität der menschen durch
staatliches handeln
die kontakte zu reduzieren aber allen
voran durch die bürgerinnen und bürger
und ihre vernunft und ihr solidarisches
handeln
das war der erfolg des relativen
volks in der pandemie das hat uns monate
im sommer erlaubt in denen wir uns
freier bewegen konnten wenngleich das
virus nie weg war und wir wissen jetzt
wir müssen die kontakte wieder
reduzieren und damit auch die gefahr der
ansteckung herunterbringen und deshalb
brauchen wir jetzt im monat november
beginnen vom 2
november noch einmal eine nationale
kraftanstrengung eine befristete
kraftanstrengung die wir auf die zeit
des monats november also bis zu seinem
ende terminieren
wir werden in zwei wochen oder nach zwei
wochen des inkrafttretens uns als bund
und länder wieder treffen und uns
anschauen wo wir stehen und
gegebenenfalls auch massnahmen anpassen
und da das dient dem zweck dann im
dezember wieder natürlich weiter unter
corona bedingungen das öffentliche leben
wieder besser gestalten zu können so
etwa wie wir es heute kennen
es sind harte maßnahmen die wir
verabschiedet haben es sind belastende
maßnahmen es sind maßnahmen für das
gesamte land und wir haben dabei
versucht auch an die politischen
prioritäten zu denken und eine dieser
politischen prioritäten war dass wir
natürlich das wirtschaftsleben so weit
wie möglich intakt halten wollen und auf
dem zum zweiten das was wir sehr oft in
den vergangenen monaten gesagt haben
dass wir alles daran setzen wollen
schulen und kitas auch offen zu halten
möglicherweise und wünschenswerter weise
mit verbesserten hygiene konsistenten
konzepten
das bedeutet im umkehrschluss wir müssen
harte auflagen machen für die
beschränkung von kontakten im privaten
und im freizeitbereich und genau dazu
haben wir heute auch die entsprechenden
beschlüsse gefasst wir noch mal darauf
hinweisen weil es oft in der diskussion
auch gesagt wird dass bestimmte bereiche
ja keine treiber der infektion sein
wir sind heute an einem punkt wo wir
bundesweit im durchschnitt
75 prozent der infektionen nicht mehr
wissen woher sie kommen
für 25 prozent können das auflisten das
heißt man kann nicht mehr sagen das
konnten wir eine zeit lang sein
man kann nicht mehr sagen dass ein
bestimmter bereich zur infektion
überhaupt nicht frei trägt und deshalb
haben wir dann in einer abwägung
maßnahmen der persönlichen kontakt
reduzierung beschlossen
das bedeutet der aufenthalt in der
öffentlichkeit ist sofort nur mit den
angehörigen des eigenen und eines
weiteren hausstandes erlaubt alles
geltend ab 2 november maximal aber mit
zehn personen aber immer nur aus zwei
ausständen wir sagen dass auch in
wohnung sowie privaten einrichtungen
private feiern oder oder auch feiern auf
öffentlichen plätzen inakzeptabel sind
wir werden hier auch die kontrollen
verstärken
wir fordern bürgerinnen und bürger auf
auf private reisen und besucher auch von
verwandten zu verzichten wenn diese
reise nicht unbedingt notwendig sind
das gilt auch für touristische und tages
touristische ausflüge und reisen
übernachtungsangebote im inland werden
nur noch für notwendige und ausdrücklich
nicht touristische zwecke zur verfügung
gestellt wir schränken die
freizeitgestaltung erheblich ein theater
opern konzerthäuser und ähnliche
einrichtungen messe kinos freizeitparks
und sind beispiele schwimmbäder
spaßbäder saunen und themen sie können
das dann im einzelnen natürlich alles
noch einmal nachlesen veranstaltung die
der unterhaltung dienen werden untersagt
gastronomiebetriebe bars clubs
diskotheken kneipen und ähnliche
einrichtungen werden geschlossen
ausgenommen ist die lieferung und
abholung mitnahme fähiger speisen und
der betrieb von kantinen
dienstleistungsbetriebe werden
eingeschränkt wir lassen die den groß
und aus einzelhandel mit auflagen zur
hygiene offen und sie schon sicher
schulen und
kitas gesprochen wollen wir auch hier
die öffnung ermöglichen
wir werden die von den temporären
schliessungen erfassten unternehmen
unternehmen betriebe selbst wenn vereine
und einrichtungen mit einer
ausserordentlichen wirtschaftshilfe
unterstützen die der erstattungsbetrag
beträgt bis zu 75 prozent für
unternehmen mit bis zu 50 mitarbeitern
für größere unternehmen müssen wir
entsprechend der maximal möglichen
europarechtlichen beihilferegelungen
unterstützen die minister scholz und
altmaier werden noch in dieser woche die
details für diese maßnahmen
hilfsmaßnahmen auch vornehmen wir wollen
die heimarbeit die mobile heimarbeit
sozusagen dort ermöglichen wo immer das
möglich ist um auch hier kontakte zu
verhindern wir werden natürlich uns in
besonderer weise auch um wilde gruppen
in unserer gesellschaft kümmern
ich will ausdrücklich sagen dass wir
weiter erreichen wollen dass menschen in
senioren- und altersheimen auch besuch
empfangen können
wir haben uns diese maßnahmen sehr gut
überlegt ich weiß dass viele sagen wir
machen wie jene konzepte wir haben uns
vorbereitet das dann sind wichtige und
großartige anstrengungen die wir so so
ist es vorgesehen ab dezember ja auch
alle wieder brauchen aber in der
augenblicklichen situation entfalten
diese hygiene konzepte nicht mehr
ausreichend die wirkung die wir brauchen
denn wir müssen aus dem exponentiellen
wachstum raus und deshalb ist das heute
ein schwerer tag auch für politische
entscheidungsträger ich will das
ausdrücklich sagen weil wir wissen was
wir den menschen zumuten
aber wir müssen den weg finden wie wir
sozusagen gesundheit sicherstellen
können in eine nationale
gesundheitsdienst hineingeraten und auf
der anderen seite weitestmöglich auch
das wirtschaftliche leben aufrecht
erhalten und deshalb bin ich sehr
dankbar dass wir nach langen
diskussionen aber jedoch eine
übereinstimmung bekommen haben
bei sehr unterschiedlichen incidents
werten in den einzelnen bundesländern
machen alle mit
und das ist für mich eine sehr gute
nachricht ich weiß dass ich hier heute
sitzt als vorsitzender der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz aber ich
möchte etwas sagen zu beginn als
regierender bürgermeister
das ist mir heute sehr schwer gefallen
diesen beschluss zu tragen und die
letzten tage die vorbereitenden
gespräche die rücksprache mit vielen
kolleginnen und kollegen die intensiven
sitzungen und beratungen auch bei uns
mit den senatsmitgliedern die haben
gezeigt dass das ein schwerer weg ist
jetzt diese beschlüsse umzusetzen
und dass wir alle miteinander auch
wissen was das bedeutet was das für
zumutung und für einschränkungen für
viele menschen sind die jetzt ob sie zu
kommen wir haben alle schon wieder ein
stück normalität auch genossen wir sind
alle gerne auch wieder in konzerte oder
ins theater gegangen oder einkaufen
gegangen haben uns gerne mit freunden
getroffen
und alles das war möglich in den letzten
monaten und natürlich war das auch immer
verbunden mit der hoffnung dass es auf
diesem weg weitergeht was wir jetzt
sehen und was sich ausdrückt in den
beschlüssen die die bundeskanzlerin
gerade vorgestellt hat ist dass es eben
so nicht weiter geht sondern dass wir
wieder an einem punkt sind wo wir harte
maßnahmen miteinander verabreden müssen
und das ist ein harter und bitterer tag
mir geht es so wie allen anderen
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten wir wollen für unser
land das beste für unsere städte das
beste das es den leuten gut geht dass
sie sich wohlfühlen dass arbeitsplätze
geschaffen werden dass es vorangeht und
dafür haben wir in berlin auch in den
letzten jahren viel getan und auch viel
erreicht und es ist auch zu sehen dass
vieles davon jetzt infrage gestellt dass
das muss man ganz klar sagen und
gleichwohl habe ich in den letzten tagen
und auch heute für den weg den wir jetzt
miteinander beschlossen haben geworden
ich habe deswegen dafür geworben dass
trotz aller bedenken die man
möglicherweise hat
und trotz dieser bitteren rückschritte
die ich gerade formuliert habe doch im
mittelpunkt stehen muss dass wir
menschen helfen müssen helfen wollen
dass es schlichtweg um menschenleben
geht das hier zu retten ist wenn wir
jetzt zu gucken werden wir vielen
menschen nicht helfen können das muss
jedem einfach bewusst sein
ich habe in den letzten tagen einen
intensiven kontakt gehabt auch mit der
berliner charité die ja auch glaube ich
bundes walters das anerkannt die arbeit
die da geleistet wird und die einen
guten überblick hat wie die situation
nicht nur in der stadt ist sondern auch
darüber hinaus auch in anderen
bundesländern
und es ist ein ganz klares bild der sich
abzeichnet die intensivbetten werden in
berlin jetzt mindestens wieder so stark
genutzt wie zu beginn der pandemie 4
märz und april
und das ist eindeutig eine entwicklung
nach oben zu sehen einer rasant schnelle
entwicklung
sie kennen diese berliner corona ampel
mit verschiedenen warnsystem was den
faktor anbelangt die inzidenz und auch
die auslastung der intensivbetten und
wir sind jetzt bei der auslastung der
intensivbetten über zehn prozent das
heißt wir gehen in diesen bereich der
nächsten warnmeldung
und das ist eben nichts abstraktes mehr
wenn man sich das anguckt sondern da
geht es ganz konkret um gesundheit unter
menschen nehmen und insofern sage ich
dass es angemessen ist in dieser
situation nochmal alle um solidarität zu
bitten und unseren weg jetzt auch
mitzutragen
solidarität gebend auch mit anderen die
gefährdet sind die schon erkrankt sind
die zu den gefährdeten gruppen gehören
die franken können solidarität mit denen
um ihre gesundheit und die eigene
gesundheit zu schützen
mir war besonders wichtig dass wir in
unserer beschlussfassung zwei drei dinge
berücksichtigen die aus meiner sicht
auch für unser zusammenleben von
herausragender bedeutung sind
das erste ist dass schulen und kitas
offen bleiben wir müssen und ich sage
das auch aus meiner perspektive wir
müssen und werden
das tun damit schulen und kitas offen
bleiben dazu sind die
unterschiedlichsten maßnahmen
gegebenenfalls erforderlich auch
vielleicht ungewöhnlicher maßnahmen und
flexible entscheidungen zu treffen sind
von der technischen ausstattung in
schulen die sich schon verändert hat
über flexible unterrichtsform digitale
angebote natürlich die eine rolle
spielen mund nasenschutz alles ideen und
abstandsregeln alles dinge die auch in
der schule mit zu berücksichtigen sind
aber es geht hier nicht nur um einen
bildungsauftrag der zu erfüllen als
sondern wir haben auch im märz und april
und in den monaten danach
ich glaube nicht nur in berlin aber auch
in berlin gesehen was für dramatische
soziale folgen hat wenn die kinder nicht
in die schule gehen können oder in die
kita
es hat konkrete auswirkungen in den
familien um es klar zu benennen es sind
gewalt übergriffe gegen frauen und
kinder in einer dramatischen zahlen nach
oben gegangen
man muss sich das vor augen halten was
das also auch anrichtet an sozialen
folgen wenn wir in diesen fragen
eingreifen müssen wenn wir also hier
nicht eingreifen wollen aus den
genannten gründen heißt das ja dass man
in anderen bereichen um so mehr machen
muss
auch deswegen kommt es in den bereichen
des sports der kulturveranstaltung der
gastronomie zu harten eingriffen damit
wir diesen herausragend wichtigen teil
des sozialen auftrages auch weiter
erfüllen können ein zweiter punkt war
mir sehr wichtig das war das
unterstützen der wirtschaft auch da
wieder spielt in berlin aber nicht nur
in berlin eine rolle
wir haben in unserem land viele klein
und kleinst selbständige solo
selbständige menschen die mit ihrer
arbeit und ihrer kraft sich selbst
finanzieren in irgendeiner
unternehmensform das ist wichtig diese
menschen nicht aus dem blick zu
verlieren
das sind oft auch die kulturschaffenden
das sind künstlerinnen und künstler aber
nicht nur das sind auch handwerker
dienstleister und und und und dass wir
gemeinsam sagen konnten bund wie länder
das ist an einer gemeinsamen
kraftanstrengung uns wichtig denjenigen
auch weiter eine
perspektive zu bieten in dieser
schwierigen phase in der wir sind
das glaube ich war von oder ist von ganz
großer bedeutung und ich denke dass das
auch zwingend erforderlich war dass wir
an dieser stelle diese signale setzen
ich will abschließend noch einmal sagen
es sind harte maßnahmen und harte
einschränkungen die wir jetzt hier
erleben aber es handelt sich um vier
wochen einige werden jetzt sagen das ist
ein verdammt lange zeit
und da vielleicht sogar dass es zu lange
währt nur einmal sagen ich will es noch
mal in den zusammenhang stellen
unsere hoffnung ist und es wird auch
bestätigt natürlich durch viele experten
dass wir damit eine chance haben wenn
wir vier wochen lang das was wir jetzt
miteinander schließen durchhalten wenn
wir das gut gemeinsam und solidarisch
umsätzen auf allen ebenen des
öffentlichen lebens das wir dann eine
chance haben diese dramatische
entwicklung die wir jetzt sehen auch zu
entschärfen dass wir eine chance haben
ähnlich wie im sommer tatsächlich wieder
ein stück sicherheit auch bieten zu
können und gut gemeinsam durch diese
pandemie zu kommen insofern noch einmal
bei der abwägung aller vor und nachteile
und auch vor dem hintergrund dass es mir
wirklich auch ganz persönlich nicht
leicht gefallen ist diesen weg
mitzutragen glaube ich gibt es sehr gute
argumente dass wir uns gemeinsam darauf
verständigt haben der ministerpräsident
wir haben eine sehr verehrte damen und
herren in der tat ein schwieriger tag
ein tag an den wir uns alle noch lange
erinnern werden und ein tag mit
schwerwiegenden abwägungen aber in angst
in zeiten muss man auch ernste und
ernsthafte entscheidungen treffen sind
wir ganz ehrlich wir haben das ja schon
länger befürchtet und auch
prognostiziert sind all die prognosen
leider eingetreten die wir seit wochen
gesagt haben wir haben auf die
entwicklung der zahlen hingewiesen auch
die tatsache dass sich unvernunft leiter
stärker auswirkt und dass die vielen
vielen die großartig mitmachen jetzt im
grunde genommen auch ein stück weit in
mitleidenschaft gezogen werden von denen
die nicht mit
oft haben und die ungünstig waren wir
haben abgewogen uns genau überlegt
welche auswirkung hat es was wir tun
kann man noch warten sondern noch hoffen
dass die zahlen sich vielleicht anders
entwickeln aber mit erschreckender
präzision haben sich all die
einschätzungen auch der führenden
wissenschaftler deutschlands bestätigt
dass heute die großen
forschungsgemeinschaften in deutschland
sich zusammenschließen und gemeinsam
eine erklärung abgeben es ist angst ist
auch ein novum passt genau in die zeit
wir haben heute abgewogen besser nichts
tun oder konsequent und klar
entscheidung zwar jetzt
ich finde man muss das tun woran man
glaubt und von dem man überzeugt ist und
ich bin davon überzeugt wie wir alle
heute bei der gemeinsamen entscheidung
dass es besser ist wenn man weiß was zu
tun ist es dann zu tun wenn es am besten
und schnellsten geht als darauf zu
warten und später schwierige
entscheidungen zu treffen
denn je länger wir warten desto
schwieriger wird es die alternative
nichts zu tun oder weniger zu tun
bedeutet am ende vielleicht die
situation zu kommen dass wir die
entscheidungen in krankenhäusern zu
treffen um über leben und tod
und das ist aus meiner sicht die falsche
ethische weichenstellung wäre es gewesen
es geht darum auch in unserem land
solidarität zu zeigen
nicht nur wenn es um die frage geht wie
viel freiheit hatte einzelnen sondern
auch wie viel schutz bietet unsere
gemeinschaft an ich denen die besonders
betroffen sind
wir sind eine solidaritäts gesellschaft
und kein eu-land es geht es auch nicht
bei den maßnahmen um loyalität zum staat
und obrigkeitshörigkeit sondern um ein
gemeinschaftsgefühl was wir alle für
unsere gemeinschaft schaffen können wir
haben festgestellt das bisher getan
reicht nicht wir müssen mehr tun
die zahlen sind so hoch dass wir uns
auch in scheiben müssen dass wir in die
3d gehen und kontakte zu reduzieren
letztlich ist das das entscheidende
motto kontakte reduzieren kontakte
reduzieren kontakte reduzieren und zwar
breitflächig drei viertel aller kontakte
sollen runter wenn man das zum anspruch
nimmt dann muss man bereits richtig
auftreten
und deswegen ist auch in der tat so dass
ich das ausdrücklich sagen es haben sich
so viele leute zu mühe gegeben
in der kultur in der gastronomie haben
so akribisch genau jene konzepte
verfolgt da auch noch mal danke schön
will auch keiner vor den kopf stoßen
genau all die bereiche die sich so
unglaublich viel mühe gegeben haben
aber fakt ist wir sind auf einem level
erreicht wo wir nicht mehr genau
nachvollziehen können nicht nur wer
infiziert ist sondern wo infektion
stattfinden und wo sie auch verbreitert
werden und sie müssen wir hier den
großen ansatz wählen um zu reagieren
dieser ansatz gilt ist für vier wochen
für den november erst vier wochen das
genau eine zeit in der wir glauben und
hoffen dass es wirkt das ist mit bittere
pille
aber wie jede therapie wäre das
medikament sind wir überzeugt und hoffen
sehr dass es auch eine entsprechende
wirkung hat es scheint kurzfristig hat
ist aber langfristig milder als die
alternativen nichts zu tun und dann eine
endlosschleife uns mit dem thema zu
beschäftigen und das ganze land leiden
zu lassen
übrigens geht es da nicht um die
gesundheitssituation sondern auch in die
wirtschaft je später wir entscheiden
desto schwieriger würde es auch für die
gesamte wirtschaft werden was ich heute
sehr stark fahren das muss ich wirklich
sagen war
wir haben jetzt schon viele mpk sie
haben uns ja schon gewöhnt an die
zusammensetzung und wir hatten häufig
sehr kleinteilige diskussionen fand das
war heute ein
in dieser schweren zeit ermunterte
signal die entschlossenheit von allen zu
spüren ich wünsche euch gesagt dass auch
in der guten zusammenarbeit wird glaube
ich die haben auch gestern schon
telefoniert gehabt bei allen kolleginnen
und kollegen auch dass viele bereit sind
die jetzt vielleicht noch nicht so wohl
incidents zahlen haben sollen wir machen
das mit und nehmen ein schwein gekauft
wir wissen was wir zum beispiel auch
unseren parlamentariern zumuten unseren
regierungskoalitionen ideen die er quasi
in diesem gremium entscheiden dass er
zunächst war nicht sehr demokratisch
legitimiert scheint das ding ist wichtig
dass wir morgen die kabinette gehen in
die landtage gehen ich werde es bei mir
am freitag tun und auch nur einmal die
zustimmung auch bieten auch von der
breiten parlamentarischen beteiligung um
das ganze zu machen wir machen nicht
einfach eine entscheidung die köpfe der
menschen hinweg versuchen täglich
mitzunehmen und zwar mit einer priorität
wie angesprochen für wirtschaftsschule
in kita schule ist auch uns ganz
entscheidend und wichtig
wir dürfen nicht zulassen dass
möglicherweise weisse corona jahrgänge
entstehen mit kindern mit schülern der
schlechtere ausbildung haben warum wird
wichtig sein schule so lange wie möglich
offen
und wenn man von der infektionsfälle
eine schule geschlossen wird dann geht
auch der grundsatz je kleiner die kinder
desto später kommt muss eine schule
schließen und je er muss sie auch wieder
geöffnet haben und mir ist auch ganz
wichtig dass unsere schulbürokratie so
flexibel wie möglich reagiert um auch
auf diese situation angepasst was
lehrpläne prüfung betrifft nicht auch
schon der kürze der zeit kindern druck
zu machen
sie haben schon ohnehin genügend druck
durch die umstände die außen herum sehen
also es ist jetzt eine nicht einfache
zeit
wir verordnen an die vier wochen
therapie wenn man es sagen kann wir
hoffen dass die dosis richtig ist dass
es erfolgreich ist wir bitten auch
herzlich diese vier wochen
gemeinschaftlich durchzustehen
wir evaluieren in zwei wochen aber wie
bei jeder therapie nicht zu früh
abbrechen sie muss würden wir dürfen
nicht den fehler machen den wir anderswo
öfter cilic zu viel wieder in den
anderen rhythmus zu verfallen
ein letzter punkt wir wollen ja keine
angst verbreiten keine panik machen
keine endzeitstimmung machen oder bei
aller schwer motive einander empfinden
will ich nur sagen es ist ja auch in
optimismus
wenn wir das jetzt gemeinschaftlich gut
bewerkstelligen
dann haben wir nicht gute basis um über
den winter zu kommen
das ist keine dauerschleife einen monat
loggt er übrigens ein milder ist als der
erste und dann wieder und dann noch
einmal und zurück es kommen in stoffe
sind im gespräch die bald kommen können
also es gibt auch anlass zu optimismus
aber wir müssen aus der jetzigen
entwicklungsdynamik nehmen wir müssen
die kurve abflachen
und dann müssen wir versuchen das ganze
anzugehen und die mehrzahl der
bevölkerung glaube ich spürte schon seit
längerer zeit dass ein solcher tag
notwendig ist und solche entscheidungen
und ich denke wenn wir das gemeinschaft
geschaffen und diese bewährungsprobe
bestehen
dann dürfen wir hinter das auch
gemeinschaftlich darauf stolz sein
deutschland hat er einmal glück dass wir
später dran waren und dann rechtzeitig
entschlossen reagiert haben wir sind
wieder später dran
wir sollten die größte stunde auch
erneut nutzen entschlossen zu handeln
und das war heute finde ich ein ein
starker tag
für die politik auch wenn es ein
schwerer tag ein ganz schwerer tag und
schwere wochen für die bevölkerung ist
aber meine überzeugenderes naja die
willkommen das sinn und wir werden
corona erneut trotzen
wir werden davon bin ich fest überzeugt
corona wir stehen es gibt doch ein
morgen- und ist wenn wir das
gemeinschaftlich schaffen können dann
haben wir für unser land und für die
vielen menschen in unserem land einen
wichtigen dienst getan
die erste frage von jörg blank dpa bitte
frau bundeskanzlerin
es hat ja in der vergangenheit oft dass
ich gezeigt dass gerade gottesdienste zu
ausgangspunkten von infektionsketten
geworden sind warum ist in dem text
nichts zu lesen
mit gottesdiensten umgegangen wird gab
es da einen speziellen grund könnten sie
den bitte erläutern
dankeschön wir haben zu den
gottesdiensten jetzt keine verschärfung
gemacht weisen aber sehr darauf hin dass
unbedingt die jene regeln eingehalten
werden muss werden wir nicht alle fälle
benannt in denen in denen das was heute
gilt auch weiter gilt
genau das haben wir nicht getan so wie
wir versucht haben zum beispiel alle
geschäfte offen zu lassen
erschien es uns nicht angemessen und
vergleichbar gottesdienste zu verbieten
medisana es gibt einen hauptgrund warum
immer kulissen ist und auch
versammlungen und demonstrationen anders
behandelt werden müssen sondern
verfassungsrechtlichen grund regions-
freiheit versammlungsfreiheit sind hoch
geschützte güter in unserem unserer
verfassung das sind gilt an der stelle
immer auch die besondere sensibilität
gegenüber diesen freiheit wir sind ja
nicht in der situation des merkt das
muss man sehen und wir haben die schulen
offen
die kitas offen alle läden offen und da
wäre es glaube ich nicht vertretbar
gewesen dann rekord es dienstags zu
machen nico fried von der süddeutschen
frau bundeskanzlerin im zumindest im
entwurf des access steht vielleicht im
ersten satz trotz der maßnahmen die bund
und länder vor zwei wochen vereinbart
haben steigt die zahl der infektionen in
starker dynamik heißt das dass das land
und die bürgerinnen und bürger jetzt den
preis dafür bezahlen dass die
ministerpräsidenten und sie sich vor
zwei wochen nicht aufrichtig weitgehende
maßnahmen einigen konnten ist es jetzt
härter als es gewesen wäre wenn man
damals weitergegangen wäre
und eine zweite frage sie sprachen von
diesem dunkelfeld von 75 prozent glauben
sie dass es als begründung gegenüber
gerade gastronomen und
beherbergungsbetrieben usw ausreicht
dass man sagt wir wissen zwar nicht dass
ihr treiber seite aber die statistik ist
so vage dass man das eben auch nicht
ausschließen kann
zum zweiten habe ich eigentlich gleich
zu beginn antworten es ist in der tat so
dass wir als wir eine geringe
infektionszahlen hatten sehr gut
zuordnen konnten wo hat man sich
infiziert inzwischen ist das virus so
weit verbreitet dass wir davon ausgehen
müssen dass es in allen möglichen
kontakten insbesondere auch dort wo man
sich dann gegenüber sitzt am tisch und
beim essen ja nur die maske erkennbar
nicht tragen kann das dort zu
infektionen kommen kann und es kann eben
überall dazu kommen und das ist ja jetzt
sehr oft gesagt worden
man könne nicht nachweisen dass die
gaststätten der treiber sind man kann
aber bei 75 prozent der fälle sowieso
nicht nachweisen was die treiber sind
und wir müssen auch noch mal anders an
die sache vielleicht herangehen herr
müller hat das gesagt und auch markus
söder die die experten haben uns gesagt
wir müssen etwa 75 prozent der kontakte
reduzieren das ist sehr viel
und wenn wir die näher kommen wollen
dann müssen es irgendwo kontakte seien
da haben wir die kontakte eingeschränkt
im privaten umfeld
da sind wir insbesondere auf die
bürgerinnen und bürger angewiesen
und dann haben wir gesagt wo können wir
noch kontakte einschränken und da sind
wir sehr stark in den freizeitbereich
gegangen und in den reisebereich weil
wir
die politische priorität haben wollten
kitas und schulen offen zu halten und
deshalb ist es also selbst wenn es mehr
fälle nachgewiesen werden könnte wo die
infektion entstehen müssen wir in
irgendwelchen bereichen kontakte
reduzieren wenn wir noch länger warten
müssen dann noch mehr kontakte
reduzieren deshalb ist die ist die
auswahl sehr bewusst getroffen worden
wissen dass das härten mit sich bringt
und wissend dass dort viel hygiene
konzepte entwickelt wurden sowohl im
bereich der kultur als auch im bereich
der gastronomie und dass sich auch viele
menschen sehr verantwortlich verhalten
haben aber in der abwägung wie kommen
wir mit der zahl der kontakte runter
ohne das wirtschaftsleben das schul und
kita leben zu gefährden haben wir uns so
entschieden und wir glauben dass das
auch verhältnismäßig und politisch
wirklich vertretbar ist die frage die
sie als erstes gestellt haben was
bedeutet das dass wir vor zwei wochen
nicht entschieden haben
rein theoretisch ist es richtig dass wir
dann hätten weniger maßnahmen oder
weniger lange maßnahmen machen müssen
auf der anderen seite brauchen wir für
alles auch eine politische akzeptanz und
die situation ist einfach so dass diese
politische akzeptanz vor zwei wochen
nicht so da war selbst wenn man
theoretisch ausrechnen konnte was wird
da das bedeutet wenn es so ist hat man
die politische bereitschaft dazu nicht
herstellen können und das liegt nicht
nur an den ministerpräsidenten sie sehen
was jetzt auch an protesten und anwohner
um verständnis dass viele sagen warum
ich und die bin ich getroffen
das wird uns noch sehr beschäftigen auch
gegenüber gerichten muss man sozusagen
evident nachweisen müssen dass
handlungsnotwendigkeit besteht und
deshalb glaube ich haben wir jetzt den
punkt getroffen an dem sozusagen
auch ein stück spielraum ist oder ich
hoffe wir haben ihn getroffen
aber auf der anderen seite auch das
verständnis wächst bei den menschen dass
etwas getan werden muss und das ist
politik das ist politik das
unterscheidet auch politik von
wissenschaftlichen man jetzt sozusagen
in der august gesagt hat guckt man hier
habt ihr die ersten anzeichen eines
exponentiellen wachstums jetzt machen
wir mal eine weile alles reduzieren wir
die kontakte ich glaube nicht dass wir
dafür die bereitschaft bekommen haben
wir sind aber auch die bereitschaft der
bürgerinnen und bürger angewiesen und
gleichzeitig sind wir verpflichtet noch
so rechtzeitig zu handeln dass der notar
nicht schon da ist und da muss ich sagen
auch gerade alle die die als experten
darüber sprechen wir sollen nicht nur
die infektionszahlen im blick haben
gerade die sind ja diejenigen die sagen
guckt doch eher auf die intensivbetten
wenn ich jetzt mal auf die belegung der
intensivbetten schauer
wenn ich sehe dass ich das alle zehn
tage verdoppelt und weiß ich habe noch
drei titeln in die ich sozusagen in
denen ich handeln kann dann bin ich
jetzt verpflichtet denn wenn die betten
einmal voll sind dann kommt immer noch
infizierte danach weil die belegung der
intensivbetten erst 14 tage oder 20 tage
also jedenfalls eine vielzahl von tage
später erfolgt und so sind wir glaube
ich jetzt in einem punkt einerseits
sichtbar ist wir müssen handeln
wir sind verpflichtet und andererseits
wo wir aber auch eine chance haben
menschen mitzunehmen und zu sagen ja
okay das sehen wir jetzt auch dass sich
das in die ungünstige richtung
entwickelt hat
kristina dunz rheinische post frau
bundeskanzlerin wie schnell können die
schnelltests für altenheime kommen wo
sich ja durch isolation und quarantäne
traumatisierung der bewohner auch schon
zeigen was es eigentlich mit bus und
bahnen die ja voll sind wo die menschen
eng stehen habe ich noch eine frage an
herrn müller
wie passt in diesen bitteren tag der
landesparteitag der spd am samstag und
herr söder macht es ihnen sorge dass die
cdu führungslos in das superwahljahr 21
geht und mit ihnen dann die
kanzlerkandidatur besprechen muss
also die städte stehen zur verfügung sie
sind als medizinprodukt zugelassen
der bundesgesundheitsminister hat eine
test verordnung unterschrieben die im
bundesanzeiger veröffentlicht ist
bereits vor zehn zwölf tagen und diese
test verordnung weist die übernahme der
kosten für dieses antigen schnelltests
für bewohner von pflegeheimen und
pflegekräfte und in krankenhäusern und
altenheimen zu
das heißt bis zu einer bestimmten länge
ich glaube dass die zahl nicht im kopf
dass bis zu einer bestimmten menge hat
jeder den anspruch dass auch in der
kasse erstattet zu bekommen und die
stehen den heimen zur verfügung ich habe
gestern einen pflegegipfel gemacht da
muss ich allerdings sagen dass man auch
sehen muss das müsste ich medizinisches
fachpersonal gemacht werden
das heißt so die die abnahme eines
solchen test es dauert sicherlich zehn
minuten bis eine viertelstunde also es
ist eine schöne zusätzliche belastung
auch für das medizinische fachpersonal
in den heimen aber es verbessert die
möglichkeiten natürlich erheblich weil
die antigen schnelltest sie ja nicht
ganz so aussagekräftig sind für die pcr
tests aber für den moment des besuchs
sind wir ihm sehr aussagekräftig und
damit haben wir ein mittel in der hand
wie wir an vielen stellen sowieso etwas
mehr mittel in der hand haben auch wenn
wir noch keinen impfstoff haben und noch
keinen durchschlagendes medikament yavuz
und bahnen wir haben vor einigen
appelliert an die länder auch im
schulbusverkehr nochmal eine
verbesserung zu erzeugen und wir glauben
und das ist ja genau der punkt auch von
der schließung von kultureinrichtungen
und von gaststätten und restaurants wir
glauben dass ich einfach der die dichte
des der benutzung des öffentlichen
personennahverkehrs oder des
fernverkehrs verändert wenn ich keine
touristischen reisen erlaube wenn ich
keine besucher einen tagesausflüge
erlaube wenn ich heim arbeit mache wo
immer das möglich ist wenn ich eben
nicht ins theater fahren wenn ich eben
nicht in die gaststätten fahrer das sind
ja alles genau solche dinge weil
dadurch kontakte vermeiden wir gehen
also davon aus dass sich die intensität
auch im öffentlichen personennahverkehrs
niederschlagen wird
zu den schnelltest möchte ich kurz
hinzufügen dass die jetzt in diesen
tagen in den ländern ankommen und ich
möchte noch mal unterstreichen dass die
bundeskanzlerin gerade gesagt hat es
entsteht so ein eindruck jeder kann ja
mal schnell den schnelltest machen
zwischen tür und angel und dann weiß man
ja wo man steht das ist schon etwas was
auch gekonnt werden muss mit dem test
muss man umgehen können der ist sehr
sensibel zu behandeln und ist ein
baustein ein baustein um ein stück mehr
sicherheit zu gewinnen wie ist gerade
die situation vor ort oder bei den
getesteten aber setzt nicht alle anderen
maßnahmen also insofern freuen wir uns
darüber dass die ihr zur verfügung
stehen wir werden sie auch entsprechend
einsetzen in den pflegeheimen natürlich
vor allen dingen krankenhäusern polizei
feuerwehr in diesen bereichen kommt er
schnellstmöglich zum einsatz
zu ihrer eigentlichen frage in richtung
berlin
die politik und die parlamente haben
auch einen auftrag und wir müssen auch
taten können und wir müssen
entscheidungen treffen können die
parlamente tagen mit mehreren hundert
mitgliedern zum teil und wir haben
wahlvorbereitungen auch zu organisieren
bundes und landtagswahlen stehen an
und dafür muss es auch in einem
geordneten verfahren die entsprechenden
entscheidungen geben die entsprechenden
grundlagen dann auch für die wählerinnen
und wähler geschaffen werden
aber natürlich in anbetracht der
beschlusslage heute werden wir auch noch
mal kritisch mit unserem landesparteitag
umgehen ich werde noch heute abend oder
morgen zu einer telefonkonferenz mit dem
landesvorstand einladen und wir werden
darüber beraten ob und wie der parteitag
stattfinden kann
gegebenenfalls gibt es ja auch die
möglichkeit dem parteitag in einer
digitalen form anzubieten um zur
entscheidung zu kommen das muss ich
jetzt allerdings auch mit dem
landesvorstand besprechen es gab ja vor
heute wurde jetzt vor diesen stunden die
wir gebraucht haben ja für die
beschlussfassung auch noch keine
rücksprache möglichkeit zu ihrer frage
sieht sein wenn ich das sage ich gerade
war nicht der tag wo wir uns mit partei
fragen beschäftigt heute sind so viele
menschen besorgt schauen auf diesen tag
wie wir zu entscheiden haben
es gibt so viel nachfragen zu
schicksalen zu existenzen dass wir uns
im moment auch glaube ich weniger um
einzelne partei fragen kümmern da bin
ich um verständnis aber eines darf ihn
auf jeden fall sagen deutschland
jedenfalls war heute und ist nicht
führungslos und das ist im moment das
entscheidende wende hielt er es
vielleicht mit reduzierter zahl der
fragen ist
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben die
zeitdauer jetzt benannt den november die
wir diese maßnahmen alle miteinander
machen sollen was mir noch nicht klar
ist wenn sie sich in vier wochen wieder
treffen oder auch in zwei wochen beraten
was ist das ziel was soll geschafft sein
ist es die 50er incidents in ganz
deutschland erreicht zu haben machen wir
das fest an der zahl der intensivbetten
an der zahl der infektionszahlen am
mehrwert mir ist einfach sozusagen die
faktische inzidenz und nicht klar und
auch wenn er selber sagt noch eine frage
hätte ich auch noch eine zweite bitte
hier sind jetzt fragen möglich sie
kommunizieren auch über die
regierungserklärung auch über den
podcast und es gibt auch andere
möglichkeiten warum er wegen sie nicht
sie haben das amt und sie haben auch die
umfragewerte sage ich mal noch mehr
bürger formate um auch den bürgern
persönlich ob per video oder analog die
fragen die sie haben und die sind ja
viele auch weiter zu erklären danke ja
ich glaube dass ich verschiedene formate
unter kroner bedingungen genutzt habe
dazu können auch andere formate kommen
in den letzten tagen war auch sehr viel
arbeit zu leisten damit wir erst mal zu
solchen beschlussfassung kommen also
alles hat seine zeit würde ich sagen
und was wollen wir erreichen das haben
wir ganz klar gesagt wir wollen die
kontakte wieder nachverfolgbar machen
wir werden die zeit nutzen auch noch mal
die gesundheitsämter aufzustocken
die bundeswehr hat noch potenzial wir
gucken auch beamten aus den bundesdienst
die vielleicht zur verfügung gestellt
werden können die länder werden das
gleiche tun
wir müssen also die nachverfolgung
wieder garantieren und wir wissen das
muss dann um die 50 400.000 in sieben
tagen liegen das kann ich jetzt nicht
für jeden einzelnen ort genau sagen
aber so wie wir jetzt im augenblick sind
in diesem sehr stark ansteigenden
kurvenverlauf ja für ganz deutschland
und man sich ja auch dieselben selbst
ländern mit einer niedrigen inzidenz tag
für tag höher steigen so darf es nicht
weitergehen also die sage dieser trend
muss gebrochen werden dass es wie so
eine welle der wir uns entgegenstemmen
müssen und unser unser punkt ist wir
müssen die kontakte nachverfolgen können
wir das nicht können dann haben wir eine
unkontrollierte ausbreitung des virus
und dann kommen verschiedene punkte an
denen wir nicht mehr hinterherkommen
dann wird werden die tests kapazitäten
knapp dann kann man überhaupt nicht mehr
ausreichend härtesten dann werden die
medikamente knapp wir haben keine nicht
von allen medikamenten beliebig viele
substanzen rente sind wir zum beispiel
ist auf der ganzen welt gefragt ist die
herstellung ist relativ kompliziert dann
kommen die intensivbetten also dann
kommt wirklich der gesamte
gesundheitliche bereich grüner lena ich
habe noch eine frage sie haben ja de
facto ein bundesweites beherbergungs
verbot jetzt hier mit heute
ausgesprochen was macht sie sicher dass
das verhältnismässig ist und nicht wie
die beherbergungs verbote zuletzt in den
ländern von den gerichten gekippt wird
und noch eine andere frage gelten diese
beschlüsse jetzt bundesweit oder haben
dass man in den nächsten tagen gelten
die beschlüsse jetzt bundesweit oder was
in den nächsten tagen wieder damit
rechnen dass es völlig unterschiedliche
interpretationen dieser beschlüsse in
den bundesländern gibt wenn die
beschlüsse gelten bundesweit deshalb gab
es ja dieses einverständnis
es gibt das bundesland thüringen wird
das parlament noch befassen das ist
ausdrücklich nochmals zu protokoll
erklärt alle müssen sich allgemein
verordnungen umsetzen da kann man auch
nicht genau aber aber so wie viel steht
gilt es bundesweit und es ist natürlich
schon ein großer unterschied zu dem
beherbergungs verbot weil das bewerbungs
verbot hat ja eine möglichkeit der
touristischen reise ermöglicht wenn ich
einen test hatte und
den vorzeigen konnte jetzt werden
touristische reisen
generell unterbunden und sind nicht mehr
möglich das ist schon ein großer
unterschied
ergänzend zu dem thema bundesweit herr
söder schon drauf eingegangen wir hatten
in den letzten tagen wirklich einen sehr
intensiven austausch zwischen allen
ministerpräsidenten ministerpräsidenten
mit und ohne kanzleramt wir haben
diverse papiere ausgetauscht
formulierung hin und her gewogen und
jetzt in dieser konferenz die wir hatten
waren wir uns alle einig der besondere
wert dieser maßnahmen liegt auch darin
dass wir hier gemeinsam tragen und dass
wir sie gemeinsam schnell umsetzen
es stimmt dass jeder tag zählt und
dieser verantwortung ist sich jeder
bewusst und wir haben alle noch in
unseren länderparlamenten und
landesregierung etwas zu erklären ich
werde mit meinem sohn auch noch die eine
oder andere diskussion führen müssen
aber alle ministerpräsidenten
ministerpräsidenten haben gesagt dass
sie voll dahinter stehen dafür werben
und diesen beschluss gemeinsam
bundesweit umsetzen wollen noch zwei
fragen auf der liste die nehmen wir noch
dran bitte mit hier einer frage herr
strempel ard vielen dank
die erste frage anhand würde und an
herrn müller wie viel vorlaufzeit
brauchen sie bis sie die gelder zum
beispiel in restaurants wirklich
auszahlen können die jetzt geplant sind
geht es schnell oder wird da in den
ländern paar tage brauchen was ja im
zweifel schlimm sein kann für die
betroffenen restaurants zum beispiel und
die frage an die bundeskanzlerin keine
freizeit keine restaurants das heißt ja
auch dass der handel dann leidet leidet
so war es ja quasi auch im frühjahr mit
dem handel dann auch noch mal extra
geholfen was das verfahren anbelangt ja
es wird schon ein paar tage dauern das
stimmt aber es war uns auch sehr wichtig
und dass es sowohl von herrn altmaier
werden von herrn scholz auch betont
worden
wir werden an bestehende systeme und
auszahlten normal antragsverfahren und
auszahlungsmodalitäten gebaut für die
zusätzlichen hilfsmaßnahmen wie der bund
jetzt zur verfügung stellt sondern wir
werden
verfahren verfahren die wir haben die
wir kennen die bekannt sind werden wir
nutzen und werden sie erweitern durch
das was wir heute beschlossen haben
insofern glaube ich es sicher gestellt
dass wir schnellstmöglich auch
unterstützen können das programm das
jetzt der punkt anbietet mit bis zu 10
milliarden euro
ist ein wirklich einmalig gutes angebot
das muss man es mal sagen
das bedeutet dass bis zu 75 prozent des
umsatzes vom letzten jahr vom oktober
2009 10 per ende juli vom november 2009
das wirkt so 2 75% des umsatzes bekommt
man und zwar mit einem sehr einfachen
nachweis wenn man sich jetzt mal
überlegt der dürfte dieser umsatz des
letzten jahres deutlich über dem liegen
was jeder im oktober hatte und keiner
darf sie auch täuschen wenn wir sagen
würden wir lassen die gastronomie
irgendwie offen was ja viele sich
wünschen
die zahlen gehen aber den letzten tagen
auch deutlich zurück weil viele leute
immer mehr biss sagt sind gibt auch
weniger leute in die gastronomie gehen
es ist ja auch nicht so dass die theater
überrannt werden bei hohen steigenden
zahlen halten sich die menschen
unabhängig von der verordnung des
staates automatisch zurück das heißt
dieses programm das ist jetzt gibt und
dass der bund aus lobt es sich außer
nicht lustig finde ist für alle monat
zehn milliarden zur verfügung zu stellen
das hat es selten in der jüngeren
deutschen wirtschaftsgeschichte gegeben
es geht nicht nur für unternehmen das
gilt auch für einrichtungen ist für
theater beispielsweise und ist auch
komplett für solo selbständige gemacht
das heißt es tatsächlich ein ganz
breites spektrum ab von denen die jetzt
in der tat durch diese maßnahmen hat
getroffen sind wenn wir noch mal
überlegt vier wochen jetzt zu schwierig
aber diesen ersatz zu bekommen ist
glaube ich also in der relation schon
ein 1er vertretbares und vernünftiges
angebot und der unterschied zum frühjahr
übrigens im frühjahr war der
einzelhandel weitgehend zu das muss man
ausdrücklich sagen da war der
einzelhandel zu und deswegen der
einzelhandel bleibt der großen bleibt
übrigens auch keine bänder stehen
irgendwo stehen
das heißt sie haben auch darauf geachtet
beispielsweise in den beschluss das
medizinische
dienstleistungen weiter gemacht werden
können alles was für einem halt mehr
anders war es schon ein differenzierter
lockdown nicht der vergleichsweise mit
einem ganz anderen wirtschafts
hilfsangebot und zwar auch konzentriert
auf die vier wochen
deswegen glaube ich dass das auch ein
ein angebot ist es heute auch all
diejenigen die wirklich auch schmerzen
haben beim thema gastronomie zumindest
eine eine finanzielle decke baut genau
und wir sind eben gehen auf die
unternehmen betriebe selbstständige
vereine und einrichtungen ein
die von den temporären schliessungen
erfasst sind das ist der groß und
einzelhandel nicht insofern
konzentrieren sich die hilfen auf die
bereiche wo die temporären schliessungen
da sind da mag es auch manchmal
mittelbare betroffene geben dass wir mit
eingerechnet aber waren wir dann lange
diskutiert aber im grundsatz ist der
handel ja offen und kann genutzt werden
die letzte frage andreas hinkel reuters
eine frage an die bundeskanzlerin
sie reden ja morgen auch mit den
europäischen staats- und regierungschefs
nachdem jetzt heute sehr deutliche
entscheidung getroffen wurde wäre es
nicht auch zeit auf europäischer ebene
nicht nur über die grünanlage zu reden
sondern auch beschlüsse zu fassen vor
allem was die grenzgebiete angeht denn
man hat ja gesehen dass dort die
infektionszahlen besonders hoch sind
ja wir haben ja ganz klar geregelt dass
reisen in risikogebiete nicht möglich
sind wenn man nicht auch da eine testung
bringt und deshalb werden wir das
natürlich verstärkt überwachen also
diese regelung bleiben mehr weiter
erhalten gibt es regeln für touristische
reisen und deshalb haben wir in dem
punkt 1415 ist das glaube ich dann auch
gesagt dass das stärker kontrolliert
werden wird durch die bundespolizei in
absprache mit den bundesländern und in
form sind zum beispiel der
schleierfahndung also hier wird man in
den grenzgebieten auch besser noch
aufpassen
viele unserer vielen europäischen der
name selber auch maßnahmen schon
eingeführt oder verstärken sie gerade
deutschland ist jetzt nicht das einzige
land was so stark betroffen ist von
virus für pendler wir wollen aber keine
grenzkontrollen über das über die
grenzkontrollen die zwischen bayern und
österreich hinaus besteht bestehen
darüber hinaus wollen wir keine
grenzkontrollen einführen aber eben
erhöhte wachsamkeit durch
schleierfahnder damit beschließen wir
diese pressekonferenz danken ihnen
herzlich einen schönen abend
tja willkommen zurück in der sendung der
tag hier im studio
jetzt wissen wir was